how's it going this is my sister Jenna
hi and I'm her sister Justine yeah hi
come on guys so we're gonna do the
sister tag we're thinking about videos
to do and ask you guys what we should do
and nobody suggested this so thanks
yeah we suggested we suggested it to
ourselves already ready for the first
question Jenna yes the first question
we're gonna skip okay number two
describe each other in one word sleepy
loud became who thought it burns haha I
don't know why number three and people
ever get you mixed up No Brianne yes yes
you not with me I'm just sort of like
the black sheep the white sheets the
real pale sheep number four what is
something that annoys you about the
other you're always sleepy but that's
great no problem we want to go do stuff
and we're just napping away and that
annoys me like I'm just gonna take my
nap but I hear her coming down the
stairs oh my gosh she's gonna want to do
something what's it like being sister
with the YouTube guru and quotes it's
fine except when you want to film on
time I'm like I just woke up I have a
rat's nest in my hair I was like brush
it and like I don't I don't want you I
don't want to be on camera
well brush did the hair and comes up and
goes in front and that's what it's like
and she says no no I say words things
your story next question do you ever
argue no matter they other than one I
want to go out and I wanna sleep exactly
what's the best thing about one another
well Justine you are very you're very
caring and giving and kind well thank
you you're very funny and sweet and kind
and caring okay well thank you so much
ah
what about Bree Bree is very nice and
kind and kiddin if she did buy me Furby
but we will talk about that Oh number
eight is ditch the dirt was I mean like
secrets
Justine's messy oh well they know that
like real messy like real messy it's
just sometimes like slight hoarding
tendencies there were ten what is our oh
oh sorry I'm is number nine what's our
favorite inside joke see my memory
summary good oh and yours not either is
there so I can't really remember what
our inside joke is quick comeback but
yeah skipping probably skip bet um
favorite memory together oh no stop it
we don't have any memory we're dumb I
lived we went to Hawaii we had a good
time yeah that was actually a lot of fun
it's like a one big memory I don't know
I don't know do you remember when I got
into the Western swimming pool yes with
a little taxi roadie
taxi
her on the radio we got to go we gonna
go kiss tricky sisters half step fall
yes each other's favorite singer I've
wanted a Kelly Clarkson or Katy Perry
for some reason I would you have these
are all those are really good I was
really not sure of any I thought for you
yeah I don't really have a favorite
singer so just goes for you
cool you like Katy Perry I do it takes
longer to get ready you know I do I like
to leave Ali I just usually don't get
ready weird get in there get out get in
get out get going get go local East
Coast Giant Eagle jokes that's an inside
joke well we have to count their I'm
sorry inside you come one right now Bob
what up bothersome aha
Ron joke though so we should play Mario
Galaxy and when you would start falling
to your death I'd like to present you
bub up and somebody joke but I'm sure
like a week it really annoyed for an so
he's like those she had no idea ah a lot
of pressure heels or flats where am I
going
why don't that doesn't say um except
they won't with me I don't have yeah I'm
not even mad about it or not we're not
mad I like you know so they make me feel
is just like a princess other than by
heels but that by then I'm like I don't
wear these I have that same problem so
pants or dresses pants sweat pants wet
when we turn this into just answering
questions I thought I was just in tears
I don't think so
I hope I don't have his wires Michael I
do okay let's just do it how we want to
do it that's fallen asleep if your house
was burning down and your entire family
was sure to be okay what would you save
and why my daugther grab my phone and
probably like my laptop or something
like everything else is sort of replace
a little bit like let me get your phone
might need it
to like call a fire department somebody
called my mom
comedy-horror chick-flick comedy comedy
blossom PMSing I want a chick flick and
I just wanna cry Blackberry or iPhone oh
yeah you're drunk you're drunk now quiet
these questions I don't even know i
googled it favorite movie
we've already talked about this we don't
really watch it don't like movies though
I do like watching them but I don't have
a favorite
what is something weird that you eat
quick you everything that you eat is
weird
it's a I don't dairy there's not weird
given you don't eat like vegetables or
meat for like and you think it's not
like you're vegan or vegetarian you're
just weird not weird weird do you guys
have anything matching oh oh too much
we got onesies we got tie-dye t-shirts
small sweatshirts and basically pretty
much our camo piece haha I'm not feeling
any of these questions because our last
question is number 23 what's your
favorite TV show Dexter fringe
well we answer them all except the first
question who's them how old are you oh
I'm 23 8 I'm 12 years old
cool well that's all the questions that
we have for the sister tag if you guys
have any other ideas for videos that are
not not that thought about doing the
baby food challenge
alright I'll see you guys later make
sure you check out gems channel it's me
Jenna E and you're on my channel your so
make sure you subscribe
cool cool see you later